bonjour à tous deuxième vidéo pour
parler des produits de chez samsung des
smartphones de samsung déjà fait une
première vidéo dans lequel vous parlez
de l'entrée de gamme la gabegie chez
samsung aujourd'hui on va se recentrer
son milieu de gamme la gamme à il y à
pas mal de produits qui sont
intéressants dans la gamme à je vous
vous démêler un petit peu tout ça pour
savoir quels produits retenir le cac
lâche t est le cas les plus intéressants
pour vous besoin et ça on va le regarder
maintenant
dans la gamme à il ya cinq produits en
tout comme ferait passe-partout 5 clés
il ya cinq produits dans la gamme à vous
avez deux produits de 2016 le a3 le à
5,2 produits de 2017 le a3 et le a5 est
un produit en 2018 c'est le à 8 alors le
eg8 a été présenté il n'y a pas très
longtemps gelé pris en main d'ailleurs
le a8 plus mais qui lui ne sort pas en
france bon c'est un petit peu dommage
en attendant sont plutôt pas mal le lien
de la vidéo est ici je vous invite à
aller les voir si vous voulez découvrir
voir les redécouvrir
bien évidemment dans cette vidéo on va
pas reprendre les caractéristiques
techniques noté ici une par une par ce
que globalement ça n'aurait pas
d'intérêt ça serait rapidement imbuvable
si je faisais une liste où on s'en fiche
façon de vous y retrouver sur internet
donc à ce moment là cette vidéo n'aurait
pas d'intérêt non non ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va regarder les produits
dans l'ensemble on va regarder par
rapport à leurs intérêts par rapport à
ce qu'on peut en faire essayer de sortir
les sens des produits et voir lequel est
intéressant pour vous lequel est à
bannir lequel il faut obtenir et lequel
il faut dégager directement point commun
entre tous ces produits vous avez des
écrans super amoled 16 millions de
couleurs sur tous les écrans
un design en verre et en métal quelque
chose de plutôt sympa des produits qui
sont assez jolis et qui globalement se
tiennent bien qui à mon sens dans
l'ensemble pour la vidéo et la photo
sont plutôt bien positionnée en faible
luminosité le plus bas qu'on a retrouvé
son capteur principal c'est du f 1.9
donc ça fonctionne vraiment très très
bien
envie de vous filmer en full hd 1920 par
1080 30 images par seconde ont
fondamentalement ça fait très bien la
faire maintenant de ses produits il y en
a qui se détache d'autres qui sont un
peu moins bons et envie c'est de
regarder un petit peu tout ça ensemble
pour moi très clairement la gamme de
2016 il faut l'oublier pas parce que les
produits sont pas bons ils peuvent faire
vraiment la faire mais parce que vous
trouverez mieux dans d'autres produits
au lieu d'acheter 1 à 3 de 2016 mieux
vaut acheter un j5 de 2017
alors effectivement laquelle j -c
l'entrée de gamme mais vous serez
gagnant là où la droite 2016 un écran
4,3 pouces le j5 2010 est un écran de
5,2 pousse donc plus grand c'est du
super amoled ça fonctionne super bien
la résolution est la même c'est juste
que vous aurez d'écran qui sera
effectivement peu plus gros sur le j5 de
là où le a3 2016 à une caméra principale
de 13 mégapixels avec une ouverture de
1.9 et une caméra de celle fidh
5 mégapixels avec une ouverture de 1.9
le 06/05/2010 est à une caméra
principale de 13 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de 1.7 donc ils captent plus
sa luminosité et une caméra sa fille de
13 mégapixels avec une ouverture de 1.9
donc côté photo ça sera beaucoup mieux
dans tous les cas vous aller filmer en
full hd 1920 par 1080 ça sera la même
chose
ce sont là trois vous avez un processeur
à quatre coeurs de 1,5 gigahertz sur le
j5 vous avez un processeur 8 coeurs de
1,6 giguère 1 3 avec 1,4 gigaoctets de
ram 2 à côté vous avez deux gigas de ram
voyez que le produit d'entrée de gamme
dans le moyen de gamme sera le tout
premier produit en tout cas le a3 est
moins performant que le j5 d'entrée de
gamme donc vaut mieux aller sur le
produit haut de gamme du bas de gamme
que le produit d'entrée de gamme du
moyen de gamme sais pas si vous avez
suivi
voilà en tout cas l'idée autres produits
a oublié de la gamme de 2016 c'est le a5
parce que le a5 de 2016 a sensiblement
le même tarif que le a5 de 2017 sauf que
entre les deux produits
il y en a quand même un qui est bien
meilleur c'est lui à 5 2010 est là où le
a5 de 2016 coup 340 euros l'autre coûte
349 euros donc pour 9 euros d'écart je
peux vous assurer qu'il est quand même
un écart en termes de caractéristiques
techniques
côté écran c'est la même chose 5,2 pose
c'est du full hd 1920 par 1080 un écran
super amoled mais là où le a5 2017 fait
vraiment la différence c'est du point de
vue de l'appareil photo au lieu d'avoir
un appareil photo 13 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de 1.9 et en façade un 5
mégapixels couverture de 1.9 votre vague
du 16 mégapixels d'un côté comme de
l'autre
avec tous les deux nous arthur ii 1.9
dans quelque chose de plus sympa pour la
photo le processeur aussi et plus rapide
la cadence et un petit peu plus élevée
au lieu de 2 gigas de ram nous avait 3
giga de ram et au lieu de voir monter
jusqu'à 128 maximum pourrait monter
jusqu'à 256 giga de capacité de stockage
maximale
bon la batterie c'est kif kif bourricot
ça change pas grand chose par contre
notre camp qui intéressant vous avez la
certification ip68 en 2017 que vous
n'aviez pas en 2016 des filtres photos
en plus enfin par un produit qui en tout
cas beaucoup plus sexy donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est que dans cette gare à
l'épreuve du 2016 on les prend on les
jette à la poubelle
on va maintenant se concentrer
uniquement sur les produits de 2010 est
à mon sens lui à 3 n'est pas vraiment
super intéressant parce que vous avez un
écart de 50 euros entre le a3 et le a5
et le a5 est quand même un cran au
dessus donc c'est pareil le as troyak
2007 on prend on le dégage maintenant le
produit qui fait vraiment la différence
mais par contre il ya vrai
un cran au niveau du budget c'est le a8
de 2018 on retrouve avec un écran 15.6
pouces super amoled en 2002 120 par 1080
séduit fhd plus c'est quand même quelque
chose de beaucoup plus sympa capteur
photo principale vous avez un 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de 1.7 et
en façade vous avez un double capteur 1
16 mégapixels un 8 mégapixels tous les
bugs en ouverture de f 1.9 qui permettra
effectivement de travailler sur les
effets boké pour avoir un mode portrait
naturel donc c'est effectivement quelque
chose de beaucoup plus précis et de
beaucoup mieux en termes de photographie
bien sûr les filtres vous avez les
autocollants qui se rajoutent pardessus
ya pas mal de choses de certification
ip68 le capteur d'empreintes digitales
qui est positionné à l'arrière qui est
d'ailleurs plutôt pas mal positionné
même s'ils n'avaient fait d'être un
petit peu plus bas on a la
reconnaissance faciale une double carte
sim qui fait son apparition dans la
gamme à de l'usb titre s'est enfin voila
c'est un produit qui est beaucoup plus
complet qui est beaucoup plus sexy mais
qui par contre coûte beaucoup plus cher
là où le a5 de 2017 coûté 349 euros le à
huit de mes 18 août 499 euros
c'est là où dans le milieu de gamme ça
commence à faire un petit peu mal on
voit effectivement que ce à lui de 2018
est vraiment un cran au dessus par
rapport à l'entrée de gamme
on se rapproche tout doucement du haut
de gamme on n'y est pas parce que la
résolution de l'écran n'est pas la même
par rapport aux produits des gammes s
c'est pas exactement la même chose mais
on se rapproche et si vous voulez un
vrai bon produit un vrai bon compromis
en dessous de 500 euros et vous avez
budget pour moi le a8 de 2018 est très
bon et si vous voulez vraiment rester
sur quelque chose de très cohérent
un budget aux alentours de 350 euros le
a5 de 2017 est vraiment super bien
c'est d'ailleurs pour moi le bilan parce
que pour moi vraiment de smartphones à
retenir dans ses produits milieu de
gamme tous les produits 2016 on les
dégage le a3 de 2017
on le dégage également on va garder d'un
côté le a5 2010 salle d'à côté
l'a8 de cette année 2018 il ya vraiment
un écart de prix 150 euros d'écart entre
les deux c'est quand même énorme
si vous voulez rester dans un budget qui
à mon avis est plus correct dans ce
qu'on appellera le milieu de gamme
c'est à dire le a5 et de 2017 à 350
euros
pour moi ces produits qui sera le
meilleur d'ailleurs si vous intéresse ou
s'est produit je vous ai mis des liens
dans la description
je vous invite à passer par rossi vous
souhaitez les acheter non pas pendant
échir et pour permettre de pouvoir
continuer de faire évoluer la chaîne
mais vous apporter toujours plus de
contenu
d'ailleurs c'est ça vous intéresse de
veto si elle laissait des jolies pousse
des commentaires dites moi ce que vous
en pensez
est ce que vous avez pu essayer tous ces
produits est ce que vous en avez eu dans
les mains
est-ce que vous en avez un tout de suite
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous en voudriez à ce que vous avez des
questions à poser
marc et matous sans commentaire parce
que on va pouvoir échanger les uns avec
les autres
je sais que notre côté des utilisateurs
y en a qui voudraient probablement
acheter et puis il ya un mois au milieu
avec une petite information donc marquer
moi tout seul je suis ton semble vous
allez voir il ya des choses super
intéressantes à retenir
merci à vous soyez sages d'ici là portez
vous bien je vous embrasse
restez connectés parce qu'il ya la vidéo
sur la gamme j ai regardé la vidéo sur
la gamme s
et puis à une vidéo à pau rétrospective
qui permet d'avoir une vue globale pour
savoir quel smartphone samsung ht en
2018 à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]